régression alors on débat de ce
spectacle démocratique et vous
l'entendez sonia devillers avait déjà
envie pour la parole bonsoir sony a pris
trice présentatrice de l'instant m sur
france inter benoît thieulin bonsoir
bonsoir bienvenue vous étiez directeur
de la campagne numérique de ségolène
royal en 2007 donc vous avez vécu de
l'intérieur un débat présidentiel
anciens présents au conseil national du
numérique et ancien doyen de l'école de
management et d'innovation de sciences
po ge accueillait le mans mathieu sous
terre mon soir soit à l'habitude et le
sens public heureux de vous retrouver et
essayiste et coauteur avec damien
fleurot de 2022 la flambée populiste
c'est publié aux éditions plon mathieu
évidemment est resté à mes côtés mathieu
croissandeau qui est toujours
éditorialiste politique ça ne change pas
entre 18 heures et 8 heures 40 qu'est ce
que vous pensez de ce débat sonia est ce
que on est au bout de la politique
spectacle ou alors comme le disait
robert badinter sur sur bfm aujourd'hui
est ce que c'est un moment important de
démocratie je pense que c'est à la fin
un grand moment d'intensité médiatique
est un grand moment d'intensité
démocratique que les deux se rejoignent
que c'est relativement rare mais que là
c'est vraiment le cas que des débats il
n'y en a pas eu que ça a cruellement
manqué à toute cette campagne et que là
pour une fois il y en a 1 maintenant
c'est une vraie question à mon avis que
vous posez thomas et qu'on se pose tous
c'est à dire est ce que la discussion
est possible quand deux candidats se
font face se font face à face qu'il n'y
a pas de socle commun pour pouvoir
discuter et que le précédent débat a été
un repoussoir monumental repoussoir
monumental un grand moment de faillite
aussi pour ceux qui ont tenté de l'animé
et qui ont échoué à le modéré ils l'ont
reconnu eux-mêmes le lendemain c'était
nous notre consoeur nathalie saint cricq
de france 2 et christophe jakubyszyn il
était patron des services politique de
la 2 et de la une à l'époque ils l'ont
reconnu le lendemain il ne s'attendait
pas à autant de violence et ils n'ont
même pas pu capter le regard des
candidats alors la presse en est
méchamment pris le lendemain oui mais
c'est une mission impossible si je pense
à tout ça on n'aura rien pu faire qu'on
s'est trompé de deux coupables le
lendemain je sais pas si vous vous
souvenez du dessin de plantu qui était
assassins on voyait nathalie saint cricq
en petites filles face à deux candidats
totalement difforme la bave aux lèvres
et sur la droite du dessin de plantu y
avait la marianne qui pleurait devant
une urne vide je pense qu'ils ont
interviewé qu'ils ont interviewé mais
c'est pas une interview enfin on va y
revenir sur son exercice ils ont modéré
le débat doit qu'ils ont c'est ce soir
là et qu'on ne pouvait rien faire face à
ces deux candidats est d'ailleurs l'un
des enjeux ou le poser bien de la grande
soirée c'est de savoir si ça va changer
parce que l'un et l'autre que ce soit et
même maquereau ou marine le pen
évidemment ils ont changé un petit
changement un dispositif oui aussi c'est
que la table ou vont être installés léa
salamé et gilles bouleau a été
considérable
donc la vraie question ils sont à
presque 8 mètres et donc cessé à
l'américaine c'est encore moins encore
moins intervenir pour attraper leur
regard comment faire pour s'interposer
entre les deux candidats qui eux ont été
rapprochés à mon avis c'est extrêmement
difficile benoît thieulin quand si on
regarde un peu les débats de ces
derniers mois y en a eu quelques-uns
alors pas avec emmanuel macron parce
qu'il l'a il l'a pas souhaité mais je
sais pas moi je me souviens du débat
entre eric zemmour et et valérie
pécresse qui était une caricature d'eux
de foire d'empoigné est ce que c'est un
risque encore ce soir pour ça oui elles
risquent effectivement suit précisément
parce que le dernier débat n'a pas
laissé un bon souvenir et que du
certaines mères c'était une caricature
et que cette fois ci pour des raisons
différentes les deux candidats ont à
donner des preuves un peu et dégage en
sens inverse on se souvient que marine
le pen avait été très déstabilisée très
agressive et avait un peu prêter le
flanc aux critiques de l'incompétence et
que de l'autre côté emmanuel macron qui
n'était pas président avait un petit
côté professoral ce qui l'a doit être
absolument éviter puisque bon ben on
sait bien que c'est une partie de ce que
lui reprochent les français d'être un
peu le candidat des élites un peu expert
un peu monsieur sachant donc oui je
pense que d'une certaine manière ça
plaide plutôt pour imaginer que les deux
candidats l'un vont avoir intérêt à
avoir un débat plus apaisé marine le pen
plus expert peut être moins agressif
plus posé et emmanuel macron peut-être
plus haut niveau d'aidé du débat avec
une capacité d écoute un peu un peu
supérieurs de l'un pour l'autre et vice
versa mathieu soupire c'est le sommet
vous l'avez dit c'est le sommet
médiatique de de la vème république tu
sais c'est comme ça depuis
1962 et l'élection du président au
suffrage universel ce moment politico
médiatique il y avait gelé 10 en
première partie 16 millions cinq cent
mille personnes il ya il ya cinq ans on
verra si on a ce n'était pas beaucoup
d'ailleurs par rapport à d'autres
d'autres débats mais il ya aussi ceux
qui ne regarderont pas et qui auront le
bruit médiatique dans les jours qui
suivront si vous mettez à la place des
candidats ou leurs conseillers
l'enjeu est enfin moi je n'arrête pas
depuis ce matin de me dire mais la dose
de stress d'enjeux qui peut y avoir même
si c'est pas ça qui va peut-être changer
le cours de cette élection c'est ça doit
être vertigineux c'est la grosse
différence avec le précédent débat avec
celui d'il ya cinq ans il y a cinq ans
était il n'y avait pas de suspense du
tout parce que juste avant je regardais
les derniers sondages en fait juste
avant le débat 2017 l'ipsos donnait de
données emmanuel macron à 59 je crois et
puis comme marine le pen a été très
mauvaise dès les jours suivants en fait
il a pris trois points et il a fini en
réalité à 67 cette fois ci on sent que
l'intérêt est moindre et on vous
comprend celle que globalement l'intérêt
pour la campagne était moindre parce que
globalement en fait l'intérêt des
français pour l'actualité a reculé de
façon significative en un an dire que
les français ont tellement souper
d'actualité au moment du coït qu' il ya
une sorte de mise en retrait au moment
de la présidentielle donc globalement il
ya un intérêt moir et puis encore une
fois c'est une finale que les français
au départ ne voulait pas rejouer in fine
et les deux finalistes sont ceux qu'on
attendait pas vraiment ça fait un an
qu'on annonce cette finale là mais les
français n'en voulait pas et pire que
cela on a deux candidats qui se font
face à face qui suscite eux-mêmes quasi
égale rejet donc je ne sais pas si les
français vont pour devrait être
massivement devant leur télé parce que
même si le l'écart est beaucoup plus
faible et le train qu'il ya un an je
vous plais cinq ans c'est tout le
paradoxe en fait ce débat est beaucoup
plus important qu'il ya cinq ans parce
que l'écart est nettement réduit et deux
parce que là je le répète quasiment à
chaque fois mais la volatilité de
l'électorat est extrême extrêmes on l'a
observé au 1er tour les sondeurs ne se
sont pas trompés les sondeurs ont pris
une photo trois jours avant le premier
tour qui n'a eu rien à voir avec les
résultats effectifs du premier tour et
donc de l'énergie mélenchon et on peut
imaginer que la volatilité reste la même
et que donc il y ait des écarts
significatifs entre les derniers
sondages et les résultats finaux et je
pense que l'extrême tension qu'il ya
autour de l'organisation du débat de la
part des parties de la part des
candidats de la part des chaînes est à
la mesure justement de l'ange de ce
débat sérieux il ne faut pas se louper
ne faut rien laisser au hasard et il ya
probablement jamais eu autant de bras de
fer
d'agressivité d'angoissé et d'impasse
dans dans la
négociation des règles on y reviendra
sur sur la forme et sur le fond mathieu
on va on va scruter avec vous les enjeux
du débat d'abord pour marine le pen
baisse et les outsiders donc d'une
certaine façon on n'a rien à perdre et
peut pas aux fins peut difficilement
faire pire que la dernière fois ce
qu'ils auraient d'une certaine façon la
libérer et jésus même au pire si c'est
un match nul elle donnera l'impression
d'avoir gagné quand vous avez perdu 6-0
et que vous faites 00 ou semblait
meilleur elle a quand même une forme
d'appréhension évidente faut comprendre
que un désir de revanche aussi vous me
direz ce débat 2017 c'est le trauma de
sa vie politique elle sait pour l l'axé
l'accident nucléaire de sa vie politique
elle a mis beaucoup de temps à s'en
remettre ça a été un angle d'attaqué
d'eric zemmour début de la campagne les
nuls et gagnera jamais on n'a vu on a vu
tout ça et son objectif ce soir c'est
également de gagner en crédibilité alors
sur la posture à la lisser son image
l'âme les chasser la maman des français
on a bien vu toute la petite musique
qu'elle essaie d'instaurer dans la
campagne et alors là elle jure en avoir
fini avec l'agressivité je sais pas si
vous avez entendu ce week-end la
brutalité cemac rond les invectives
cemac rond les attaques ces macro enfin
bref elles essaient de tout mettre sur
le dos du président elle elle dit
qu'elle veut un débat calme posée c'est
une nouvelle marine le pen et même son
entourage dit on va faire un débat
chiant
alors quelle attaque bien sûr flanqué de
l'attak évidemment sur son bilan on
connais ces éléments de langage parce
qu'ils ont été érodées par ses
lieutenants enfin son lieutenant
puisqu'on a dicté leur séjour dambach
des lacs a quasiment tout fait dans
commun comme débat de dans l'entre-deux
tours tout ça va être le pays fracturé
les gilet jaune à crise sanitaire et
j'en passe la retraite à 65 ans
évidemment le recours au cabinet
mckinsey voilà tout tous les éléments de
langage qu'on a entendu et l'autre axe
du débat pour elle au delà de la taxe et
de déminer alors on a vu qu'elle a
commencé à le faire elle l'avait fait
dans son programme puisque son programme
est un programme qui aiment moins un
programme de rupture pour 2017 elle a
fait aussi dans cet entre-deux-tours sur
des questions où elle a été un peu
embêté l'interdiction du voile dans
l'espace public vous avez vu cette
espèce de rétropédalage on sait plus
bien alors que ça sera pas pour les
dents mer mais qui est une grand mère
bref elle elle continue un peu à
patauger mais elle a tenté en tout cas
en amont de ce n'est pas parce qu'elle
savait que c'était un point où elle
pouvait se faire taper par une belle
macro et puis elle doit à tout prix
montrer que son programme
c'est non seulement plus un programme
d'extrême droite ça c'est ce qu'elle a
tenté de faire pour attirer les
électeurs jean luc mélenchon notamment
mais elle doit aussi montrer son
programme est réaliste et ça c'est très
lourd au bois elle parce qu'avant le
front national leur assemblée nationale
c'était un parti de slogans à partie de
la tentation en partie de colère un
parti protestations s'étaient pas un
parti de gouvernement hélas le saut
qualitatif qu'elle doit faire ce soir
est énorme alors nous dit qu'elle a
travaillé ça ça a été aussi un élément
de langage
travail et marine le pen elle est bien
meilleure et alors on va voir ce soir ce
que ça donne devrait redémarrer pour
emmanuel macron justement les enjeux
alors lui c'est le favori donc lui n'a
donc rien à gagner ce soir
l'écart dans les sondages se creuse
depuis le premier tour il est sorti
vainqueur haut la main du débat d'hier
2010 est donc rien ne serait pire pour
lui que de faire moins bien que la
dernière fois où jeu égal avec son
adversaire mais ce débat il l'attendait
il l'a même tout fait aux courses en
quête de ce que de son quinquennat pour
imposer ce duel final contre marine le
pen les progressistes contre les
extrêmes les nationalistes contre les
européens le camp du bien contre le cour
du mal bref voyez toute la petite
musique qui nous a chanté il avait même
tellement envie de cette deuxième manche
que son équipe a tenté d'en avoir
plusieurs des bars pendant cet
entre-deux-tours un moment ce que
l'état-major de marine le pen a
évidemment refusé parce qu'il n'en était
pas question pour elle lui sur la
posture ils courent un risque évident
c'est ce côté élèves insupportable bonne
élève insupportable monsieur je sais
tout qui va réponse à tout et est ce qui
renforcerait son image d' arrogance qui
lui colle à la peau c'est pas tout mais
ça compte beaucoup il pourra pas changer
ce soit de ce soir de personnalités
emmanuel macron mais il doit gommer les
excès sont deux maîtres mots elle cette
extrémité lui c'est humilité sur le fond
il a passé son antre de tour essayer de
le diaboliser la re diaboliser je vais
te dire pour tenter de ressusciter le
front républicain il agite et l'extrême
droite mais ça suffira pas et dans son
équipe il faut s'attendre ce soir ils
disent qu'il faut s'attendre ce soir
plutôt à l'avoir attaqué son adversaire
sur le plan de la crédibilité dans tâche
sur les conséquences économiques et
sociales son programme dévoilé
sur l'extrême droite les angles
d'attaqué ça sera le programme non
financées ça sert les discriminations
quand même le coup d'état institutionnel
vous savez tout la rénovation
institutionnel je veux faire un marine
le pen lui son objectif c'est de la
rendre inquiétante encore plus
inquiétante qu'elle ne l'ait puisqu'on a
vu que dans le sondage doxa dont on a
parlé tout à l'heure c'était quand même
un trait de caractère de la dn1 traits
d'image sa faiblesse à lui c'est son
bilan parce que il est aux manches
depuis cinq ans et que donc chaque
proposition tu as fair value à
travailler dans la figure sur le thème
pourquoi ne l'avez vous pas fait avant
et puis ensuite c'est son programme qui
ressemble davantage à une addition de
mesures qui est un projet y a pas de
vision il ce qui est dommage pour lui
c'est que la seule mesure que les
français retenus c'est cette fameuse
retraite à 65 ans sur laquelle lui aussi
était ogier de rétropédaler bref afin de
ratisser le plus large possible il va
devoir continuer d'adresser des signaux
à la gauche sans dénaturer son projet on
vous rester lui-même tout en promettant
d'être un autre et c'est un sacré
chantier séduit l'air le débat il sera
forcément différent ce soir parce que
l'une et l'autre ont changé c'est
simplement et ce sera chiant pour
moi je pense que ce sera
comment dire ce n'est pas un débat ce
n'est pas une réunion électorale c'est
un show télévisé c'est un spectacle il
faut quand même bien savoir que ce débat
de l'entre-deux tours il n'est pas
inscrit dans la constitution
c'est un spectacle ils n'y sont pas
obligés tout le monde s'étonne que ce
soit une sorte de co-construction tout
le monde s'étonne que les parties aient
leur mot à dire
mais en réalité c'est encore une fois
ils n'y sont pas obligées on fabrique
une un moment de télévision tous
ensemble alors après je pense que c'est
assez dommageable toutes ces discussions
qui fuites dans la presse sur je récuse
anne sophie lapix et cinq ans avant je
récuse anne claire coudray et qu'on
gagnerait beaucoup à avoir un modèle
comme au canada comme aux états unis
avec des commissions parlementaires
pluripartite bombe bipartisane
évidemment avec des règles du jeu écrit
de valider écrite validé rediscutée tous
les cinq ans par une commission où tous
les partis sont représentés et on laisse
les on laisse les équipes de campagne en
dehors de ça on laisse les candidats en
dehors de ça ce que d'ailleurs donald
trump n'a absolument pas supporté est ce
que les républicains sont en train de
mettre à bas aux états unis ce qui est
extrêmement grave c'est à dire que
personne ne sait pour la prochaine
échéance électorale aux états unis si on
pourra encore faire un débat tellement
trump a démoli système qui marche est
formidablement bien depuis les années 80
on aurait peut-être on aurait peut-être
intérêt à ça parce que je pense que dans
cette période terrible où la confiance
dans les médias besse où la suspicion
est partout le fait que certes ce sont
les chaînes qui ont proposé gilles
bouleau et léa salamé mais il a fallu
qu'il soit validé par les parties en
tout cas qu'il ne soit pas récuser je
trouve que c'est assez lourd à porter
aujourd'hui pour des pour des
journalistes et c'est dommage que ça se
passe comme ça c'est ce qu'ils ont dit
l'un et l'autre sur votre antenne fillon
les avait reçus hier on écoute gilles
bouleau qui parle de théâtralisation
gilles bouleau si on considère qu'un
débat présidentiel qu'un enjeu
extraordinairement important c'est aussi
par donc de dire c'est pas une pièce de
théâtre mais il ya une dramaturgie oued
est plein il ya des dossiers il ya des
temps forts voilà à deux joueurs de
tennis y en un qui est au meilleur sur
terre battue look est meilleur sur dur
donc sur les thèmes que nous allons
aborder la sécurité la politique
étrangère la jeunesse que sais-je chacun
des deux camps peut considérer que son
champion est plutôt à l'aise ou plutôt
moins
bonne atteint je le rappelle vous
faisait partie de l'équipe de campagne
de ségolène royal en 2007 comment elle
s'était préparée
elle s'était préparée d'abord repos
c'est je pense que l'idée de dice compte
à un moment donné et se concentrer sur
la préparation de ce débat est essentiel
ensuite on fait d'abord le petit jeu qui
consiste à essayer de se mettre dans la
tête de l'adversaire donc bah c'était de
faire travailler ses équipes sur qu'est
ce qu'il pourrait dire quelles sont ses
faiblesses qu'elles vont être ses angles
d'attaqué est donc bon à l'époque
c'était assez clair d'ailleurs l'idée
c'était on pensait que sarkozy était
quelqu'un de ces excités un peu
agressifs et donc l'idée c'était le
pousser à bout je me souviens d'ailleurs
qu'il y avait eu tout un débat technique
d'ailleurs qui sait pas qui étaient déjà
présents auraient dit et je trouve que
là c'est devenu un peu caricatural mais
c'est déjà présent je suis un qui a eu
un débat assez long pour savoir quelle
serait la température du studio parce
que on voulait que nous nous rouler du
côté voilà on voulait une température
assez élevée pourquoi exactement et sa
garde et pas très très dur que nicolas
transpirait
ça a été un vrai débat je suis même
d'ailleurs pour moment ont visité les
studios qu'on était là avec un avec un
thermomètre vérifier que la température
était là je suis quelqu'un de l'équipe 2
quant à dire un coup de pied dans un des
climatiseurs 10 ans
était déjà assez assez technique alors
ensuite évidemment le maître mot de
l'entraînement c'est tout simplement
d'avoir quelqu'un qui va peut faire le
sprint à feurs m'ont parlé en mauvais
français et qui va se jouer au jeu des
questions réponses et d'essayer de se
mettre dans d'entraîner en fait le
candidat donc ça a été c'était un moment
c'est des moments d'intense préparation
et puis je pense qu'il faut le dire
aussi alors je sais bien que on a
toujours tendance à penser que les
sondages sont peu affectées au fonds et
et disons et que le débat du deuxième
tour au fond n'a pas l'impact mais en
tout cas pour les équipes de campagne
c'est un moment extrêmement important
même quand et nous en 2007 à ce moment
là de sa mère les jeux étaient faits ans
avec les sondages était assez important
mais au sein des équipes de campagne
adjoint lueur d'espoir c'est là qu'on
continue toujours de penser jusqu'au
dernier moment que eh bien ça peut
bouger dans un sens ou l'autre des
fonderies du coup l'ultime moment de ce
changement cesser le débat de
l'entre-deux tours et est par ailleurs
on sent aussi consommer c'est quasiment
une institution d'herbe notre marque est
très juste c'est à dire que parce que
c'est quasiment une institution peut se
poser la question à savoir pourquoi est
ce qu'elle est pas inscrite un peu plus
fins durement dans les normes
constitutionnel ou en tout cas politique
et c'est une institution et donc ça veut
dire aussi que quand on y participe on
se remémore tous les autres débats qui
ont eu lieu et la celui là ce soir il
est assez inédit à ce titre aussi parce
que c'est la première fois depuis 80
qu'il ya un match retour pour faire
plaisir à monsieur boulot qui prend
souvent cette métaphore est donc c'est
aussi ça l'enjeu c'est à dire qu' on ne
peut pas arriver à ce débat ce soir
conçois qu'on soit marine le pen ou
qu'on soit maintenue à la tron
les
environs se remémorant quelques-uns des
grands moments de ces débats c'est notre
mémoire collective ou didier de match
retour auquel il faut comparer ce débat
ce soir parce que c'est exactement la
même situation un jeune homme président
il était l'adjoint de la vème république
qui avait pris le pouvoir de façon un
peu spectaculaire action voilà par
l'effraction contraint candidats qui
s'étaient présentés pour la troisième
fois comme une peine juste qui avait
dépoussiéré son programme en avoir dans
le programme commun pour le rendre plus
présentable n'est pas l'esprit qu'il y
avait perdu de façon acceptable dit lui
même françois mitterrand à propos du
débat de 74 le débat et qu'il voulait
tenir sa revanche face à un président
giscard d'estaing qui était professoral
et arrogant croissandeau que le débat de
l'entre-deux-tours à la télévision a été
créée justement en 74 et que serge moati
cette année là qu'il a créé et qui la
consultent à élaborer les règles comme
promis marion vivre peut nous rejoindre
sur ce plateau re bonsoir à marion donc
coup coup d'oeil dans le rétroviseur je
parlais mémoire collective
les temps forts qui ont marqué ces
débats présidentiels et je vous propose
de commencer par celui qui a battu des
records d'audience nous sommes en 1988
françois mitterrand et jacques chirac
s'affrontent dans ce débat d'entre deux
tours nous sommes en pleine cohabitation
et la tension est vive entre les deux
hommes petit rappel vous l'avez évoqué
depuis 1974 bas du premier débat
télévisé ces émissions sont vues en
moyenne par 21 millions de français mais
en 1988 ils sont 30 millions de
téléspectateurs devant leur poste a
assisté donc à ce duel électrique avec
en particulier cet extrait qui a fait
date souvenez vous
permettez moi juste de vous dire que ce
soir
je ne suis pas le premier ministre et
vous n'êtes pas le président de la
république nous sommes deux candidats à
égalité
et qu'ils se soumettent au jugement des
français
seuls qui comptent vous me permettrez
donc de vous appeler monsieur mitterrand
vous avez tout à fait raison monsieur le
premier ministre voilà françois
mitterrand qui fait partie des grands
débatteurs de cette 5ème république on
connaît son talent de répartie
d'éloquence et pourtant en 1974 c'est
valéry giscard d'estaing qui fait mouche
dans le débat dans son autobiographie le
pouvoir et la vie il explique d'ailleurs
que c'est une phrase en demo qui l'a
propulsé à l'elysée et je vous propose
justement de revoir un extrait et cette
phrase mythique justement je trouve
toujours choquant et blessant de
s'arroger le monopole du coeur vous
l'avez par monsieur mitterrand le
monopole du coeur on ne l'avait pas en
2007 maintenant nicolas sarkozy affronte
on en a parlé ségolène royal c'est la
première fois qu'une femme est présente
un en second tour d'une élection
présidentielle et le débat sera
notamment marquée par la colère de la
candidate socialiste qui s'en porte sur
le thème de l'accueil des handicapé qui
attaque directement le candidat de
droite avec cette phrase non je ne me
calmerai par an fin du débat de 2012 on
retient évidemment l'anaphore de
françois hollande ce fameux mois
président qu'il va répéter 15 fois en
l'espace de trois minutes c'est une
attaque directe du bilan du quinquennat
de nicolas sarkozy françois hollande qui
se revendique on se rappelle le
président normal et le dernier débat on
en a beaucoup parlé mais ça va être
intéressant de de détail et peut-être de
revoir un extrait la contre-performance
de marine le pen marine le pen
approximative qui cherchent des éléments
dans ses fiches et qui se révèle très
agressive une attitude qui mine sa
stature présidentielle notamment lors de
cet échange ouailles et puis tout
regarder
ils sont dans les campagnes dans les
vies par les deux sur les réseaux
sociaux je vois là alors ce débat a été
suivi par 16,4 millions de
téléspectateurs c'est le score le plus
faible de tous les débats d'entre deux
tours c'était pourtant la première fois
qu'un candidat d'extrême droite du
rassemblement national il participait
puisqu'en 2002 jacques chirac avait
refusé de débattre avec jean marie le
pen le candidat frontiste je cite
jacques chirac il ne peut pas y avoir de
débat possible face à l'intolérance et à
la haine et signe que les français sont
attachés à cet exercice un sondage csa
pour le parisien avait révélé quelques
jours plus tard que 69% des français
regrettait ce souchon et cette absence
de débat merci mario devoir
ravi goûter ses produits tout faits
graves ravivé le souvenir c'est le bon
je cherchais il a fini par arriver c'est
toujours bien des extraits que qu'on a
qu'on a choisi et qui sont tirées du
documentaire duel présidentiel réalisé
par hull non six documentaires à revoir
gratuitement en replay sur
publicsenat.fr mathieu soutien on va
revenir sur l'histoire des règles de ce
débat est ce que vous trouvez ça
finalement normal que ce soit co
construit pour reprendre l'expression de
sonia devillers oui parce que comme vous
le disiez à l'instant on fait ça
participe de la campagne et a racheté
vrai que c'est un meeting filmé mais ça
s'apparente à sa réalité on pourrait
imaginer un débat sans journalistes en
l'occurrence on pourrait amis imaginez
juste une joute électorale entre les
deux et en grillant 74 à vendre un
terrain mais c'étaient les candidats qui
posait des questions à l'autre les jours
et même inutile et le deal avec les
journalistes était bien celui ci les
journalistes étaient en retrait et
uniquement présent pour comptabiliser la
répartition du temps de parole mais pas
du tout pour animer les échanges et et
ça dit bien en fait que ce temps est
important alors je sais que l'analyse
dominante consiste à dire que ces débats
sont sans impact ou avec un impact
mineur mais je rappelle tout à l'heure
qu'en 2017 quand même l'agente ann
absolue de marine le pen se traduit dès
le lendemain par une chute dans les
sondages et si on remonte aux débats de
2012 que vous évoquez à l'instant en
lités alors que françois hollande dans
les sondages est certes devant mais il
ya un faux plat dans sa dans sa campagne
et il y a une forme de remontée de
nicolas sarkozy dont tout le monde se
souvient dans les dernières semaines et
si précisément françois hollande
parvient à endiguer la remontée de
nicolas sarkozy c'est avec deux choses
il sort de sa de 2 de son chapeau la
taxe à 75% de façon quasi improvisé dans
une émission de télévision et deuxième
dimension précisément c'est la fameuse
un fort qui fait que nicolas sarkozy
n'arrive pas à ce moment là à se refaire
et c'est très important parce que
nicolas sarkozy aurait dit lui même
après le débat que il l'a raté et il l'a
perdue parce que précisément après cinq
années passées à l'elysée il n'a plus du
tout l'entraînement l'expérience du
débat et je pense que healy un point
pour emmanuel macron qui en général en
tout cas c'est ce qu'on dit a plutôt
tendance à se faire confiance à lui même
à être assez sûr en fait de son
intelligence et de son niveau et il n'a
pas d'entraînement depuis cinq ans et
donc de ce point de vue là ils sont un
peu affront à fronts renversés je
rebondis sur ce que disait pote benoît
tout à l'heure ils ne sont pas dans le
même emploi et ils ne sont pas
exactement ils n'abordent pas le débat
avec les mêmes avantages l'un et l'autre
faut pas la part d'intox à un procès qui
peut y avoir un souvenez vous la
dernière fois sa recette qui a très bien
réagi macro et est invité sur bfm la
veille ou l'avant veille du débat et
eddy laisse entendre une fuite enfin en
discutant avec jean liste après
l'interview que si jamais c'est trop
progressif et qui tracera il s'en va et
donc évidemment s'est répétée et donc
marine le pen actionner le phosphore
avec ses experts et qui se dit de façon
elle est très en retard et son âge fait
lui péter les plombs près et donc c'est
pour ça qu'elle valait la salle aux
impôts mais la somme dès le début et
tout le monde est comme ça parce que on
n'a jamais vu ça c'est vrai que ce débat
était spectaculaire de 2,8 violences au
début et en fait lui la laisse venir et
elle s'épuise elle sait qu'elle ne peut
plus changer de rythme c'est très
compliqué tout petit complément
effectivement je pense que pour emmanuel
macron ce débat est beaucoup plus
difficile qu'il ya cinq ans parce qu'il
est le sortant comme on l'a déjà dit 2
parce qu'il a peu d'expérience du débat
là où marine le pen on a quand même fait
beaucoup et y compris au cours de ces
dernières semaines et puis la troisième
dimension encore une fois les scores
sont relativement serré même si encore
une fois tous les sondages donnent
emmanuel macron gagnant les scores sont
relativement serré l'électorat est très
volatile l'abstention est un critère
tout à fait déterminant et pourrait
macron c'est plus difficile en lités
emmanuel macron doit convaincre de
potentiel abstentionnistes de venir
voter pour lui là où marine le pen peut
se contenter en fait de dissuader
d'endormir ces fameuses absentionnistes
pour qu'ils restent sur leur canapé je
reviens aux règles qui ont été négociées
et notamment cette soir de plans de
coupes sur les sur les fiches pas parce
qu'il ya une scène
l'a50 l'invs et s'alimente marine le pen
un peu perdu dans ses fils là on n'aura
pas ce soir c'est tous les cinq ans les
français prennent une leçon de cinéma
c'est à dire personne ne parle de plan
de coupe pendant cinq ans une fois tous
les cinq ans la france entière d'avoir
se demande ce que c'est qu'un train de
coupes et ensuite tout le monde a un
avis sur les plans de coupe alors un
plan de coupe c'est vous êtes en train
de parler et voilà je suis en plan des
coûts exactement et donc du coup on voit
sur votre droite ce sous-traitant plans
de coupe donc on entend en stéréo la
voix de sonia devillers sauf que on voit
à l'antenne mathieu sous caire où thomas
hugues et on voit sur son visage toutes
les mimiques
effaré ou au contraire ricanant ou
cherchant dans ses fiches ou transpirant
et c'est bon manifestement c'est ça qui
a tué entre guillemets marine le pen la
dernière fois ça qu'à beaucoup de plans
de coupe qui lui ont été fatals et là il
ya eu évidemment grande négociation sur
les plans de coupe il semblerait que
didier froehly les dit le réalisateur on
régresse là dessus c'est à dire qu'on
avait acquis une forme de liberté
en 2017 sur ses plans de coupe
évidemment qu'ils sont révélateurs moi
j'ai entendu didier froehly un matin sur
france inter dire ça n'a pas grand
intérêt on n'est pas là pour piéger ou
bien alors que si tout est là en règle
donc c'est très dommage si on a réussi
arca menacé cet exercice télé alors
qu'on avait réussi au contraire un petit
peu a dérégulé et à le libérer ce sera
très dommage moi ça fait partie des
choses que je veux absolument en scruter
le pen qui l'a qui a provoqué cette
régression médiatique probablement
probable fait partie des négociations
il ya un élément qui me semble très
important dont on n'a pas encore parlé
c'est la part d'eads et des commentaires
du lendemain et notamment des médias
sociaux des réseaux sociaux match et
vous connaissez et ô combien sur ce
domaine
ça va aussi jouer là c'est à dire qu'il
ya la suite du débat je pense qu'il ya
un méta débat au fond c'est aujourd'hui
voilà en direct il ya des gens qui
commentent et il ya des batailles
l'espèce de guerre l'information une
battle qui se produit en parallèle sur
le deuxième écran que sont ces
téléphones qu'on a entre nos mains et
qu'on consulte autant qu'on regarde le
débat à la télévision et donc oui le
fait d'avoir comme ça alors ni militant
des journalistes aussi qu'ils vont faire
du fact checking en live tout ça fait
qu'il ya deuxième débat autour du débat
qui va compter et qui va être
déterminant et ça je me souviens déjà de
l'époque en 2007 la bataille du
lendemain ou du soir même sur qui a
gagné avant que les premiers sondages
soient publiés alors maintenant c'est
quasiment en temps réel donc ça change
un peu et aussi déterminante serre que
si pendant deux jours on dit intel a
gagné ça va évidemment donner une image
notamment pour celles et ceux qui leur
ont pas vu sonné et oui ou à ceux qui en
fait ont du mal à se faire une opinion
c'est tout simplement ou qui hésitent
donc à il ya bien un débat qui prolonge
une espèce de troisième mi temps du
débat de l'entre-deux tours qui va du
coup posée selon qu'on agite les médias
aussi les réseaux sociaux c'est un crash
test pour les deux modérateurs serre ce
qui s'était passé en 2017 c'est que la
presse avait été assassiné avec nathalie
saint cricq et christophe jakubyszyn
lendemain disons qu'ils avaient toutes
échoué qu'ils étaient absents excusés
avait été dépassée tout le temps les
réseaux sociaux avaient plutôt défendu
nathalie saint cricq en disant devant
c'est la seule qui a essayé elle est
montée au créneau elle a tenté elle a
fait ce qu'elle a pu et elle a tenté de
sauver de sauver la partie allait
alexandre poussard est toujours sur
place aux studios du lendit rebond soit
alexandre les candidats sont ils arrivés
c'est 19h22 c'est la bonne question
est oui c'est la question qui se pose
thomas alors non ils ne sont pas encore
arrivés ils devraient arriver aux
alentours de 19h30 20h et ils vont
arriver sur ce très beau tapis rouge qui
a été déroulé pour l'occasion emmanuel
macron et marine le pen qui seront
accueillis par les directions de france
2 et tf1 qui organise ce débat ensuite
eh bien ils vont aller devant ce très
grand mur tricolore pour faire de belles
images de l'arrivée des candidats pour
ce débat d'entre deux tours d'ailleurs
on commençait à enlever quelques
barrières ça signifie que les candidats
vont arriver d'une minute à l'autre tout
est en train un peu de se mettre en
place on voit notamment des conseillers
de marine le pen qui arrivent comme
philippe ballard un conseiller régional
et rennes d'ile-de-france et puis les
journalistes en duplex ici au studio de
saint denis sont aussi en train de se
mettre en place pour couvrir cet
événement est d'ailleurs là on enlève
toutes les barrières donc ça veut dire
que les deux candidats vont vraiment
arriver de manière imminente et on
suivra ça évidemment on sera on sera de
nouveau présent à partir de 20h30 avec
brigitte boucher sur une ou deux
antennes des chaînes parlementaires et
puis le débat sera diffusé en direct sur
nos antennes à 21h je le rappelle 21h
comment ça va se dérouler alexandre
alors eh bien là c'est très codifié très
encadrée c'est marine le pen qui va
prendre la parole en premier pour les
prises de paroles d'introduction ensuite
plusieurs thèmes vont être abordés le
premier thème c'est le thème du pouvoir
d'achat qui va être et bien débattu
entre les deux candidats c'est un thème
qui est plutôt favorable à marine le pen
et puis ensuite les candidats vont
parler des questions internationales de
la guerre en ukraine de la sécurité de
l'environnement du modèle social avec la
fameuse réforme des retraites de la
jeunesse ou encore de nos institutions
ce débat il va durer 2h30 il devrait se
terminer à 23h30 et les deux candidats
finiront par une carte blanche cette
fois ci c'est emmanuel macron qui va
conan qui va commencer et c'est marine
le pen qui conclura merci alexandre pour
ça pour tous ces détails on sera là
évidemment après le débat à partir de
23h30 peut-être 23h40 pas vous mais
d'autres invités pour débriefer en tirer
les premières leçons je trouve que c'est
limite une faute de goût le tapis rouge
moi ça me choque souffre il ya un
côté spectacle
people j'ai dit paul la can les oscars
oui il ya aussi des tapis rouge à
l'elysée quand on quand on reçoit
en robe de soirée et là c'est pas une
soirée de gala à mon avis est ce qu'il
faut multiplier les débats mathieu
soutien parce que là finalement il y
aura eu un débat entre les deux tours si
on prend l'exemple américain en a
plusieurs et ce qu'il faut
institutionnaliser je reprends un peu ce
que vous disiez tout à l'heure c'est à
dire codifié institutionnaliser le
nombre de débats à débat de premier tour
entre tous les candidats le nombre de
débats entre les dans les quinze jours
qui séparent le 1er du tout alors que je
constate en tout cas c'est qu'on a parlé
pour cette campagne d'une campagne sans
débat on s'est beaucoup plaint du fait
qu'on n'était jamais entrée dans la
campagne or je n'ai pas fait des comptes
mais j'ai le sentiment que en terme de
débats de son âge et b mission visant à
commenter les débats on n'a jamais eu
autant pas sûr que lors de cette
campagne encore une fois il y a deux des
trois demi finalistes qui sont entrés en
campagne à un an et demi ou deux ans
jean luc mélenchon et marine le pen et
même si emmanuel macron les sorties du
bois extrêmement tard en réalité entre
la primaire écolo la primaire des
républicains l'explosion du phénomène
zemmour à l'automne en lités on a mangé
de la campagne électorale et nuit débats
pendant des mois et des mois ça n'a pas
suffi à ce que l'opinion pour autant
considère que s'il y avait des débats
alors peut-être que l'opinion considéré
que les débats n'étaient pas au niveau
de ce qu'ils attendaient que à aucun
moment match à 12 comment qu'ils
attendent à un match à 12
en 2017 ensuite on voit bien que déjà un
match à deux c'est compliqué à arbitrer
alors un match à 12 on a du mal à
imaginer les résultats que ça peut
prôner bien sûr il ya eu l'idée m'a
peut-être pas beaucoup sur le fond quand
même un nom ça a été des débats sur
quels candidats quelles alliances un
tout oui faut-il une primaire à primaire
on a eu beaucoup de débats le
maire de la droite
que ça je dis rien très longtemps on a
parlé de s qui sera candidat par
candidat ça vire a pas de virage même en
sortant du débat mélenchon est mou enfin
en été on a douze candidats sur
l'étagère et et qui vont de poutous à
eric zemmour donc l'offre politique est
quand même assez large et à la fin les
trois demi finalistes quand même incarne
trois projets solides politique déçu
tout à fait différent tout à fait
différent et je dirais que aucun des
trois n'est totalement dénué de talent
tard on a plutôt trois représentants
politiques de bon niveau donc à la fin
en réalité on pourrait avoir trois
projets de société incarné par trois
personnalités politiques d'envergure qui
débattent et qui produisent dans le bas
dans la population quand même un moment
au citoyen important merci beaucoup à
tous mathieu soutient le titre de votre
livre 2022 la flambée populiste et
publié chez plon l'instant mca keller
déjà sur france2 fr car 9h40 il faut
être là très bon rendez vous quotidien
sur inter merci encore d'avoir participé
à ce débat